In the previous video, you saw us renewing anold pickup truck.
And in this video, we're going to upgrade
an old shipping container for futurestorage and materials.
We will start by making a big roof above it,
and we're going to share allthe drawings with you...
So you can use it for your own container,
if you have one laying around...
But, first things first: we need a shipping container...
And we got one a few months ago,
in the middleof a rainy winter...
Our land?
It's a bit rough with the dirt roads...
So we had to move it toa more sketchy truck,
to bring it to the land.
We are now in the back of Basekamp!
Wecleared all these mimosa patches...
We cleared all this area, where the containeris going to come...
Then, we have put these concrete pieces,
to let the container rest flaton top.
Now that it's raining, the container needs to come by the path...
We also cleared the path for thetruck.
Let's see how it goes...
Coming in five minutes!
Looks good...
huh
looks good!
Good!
I'm impacted with thisrain, but the driver is badass.
Happy, for a new dry space!
So here we have the container!
It's currentlyspring...
It's been here since the winter.
We put some stuff inside, to make sure it
was protected fromthe rain.
But now, the sun is coming,
and it's time to rebuild this beautiful container.
So when wegot the container we made a patch
free from vegetation, where we could put it.
But everythingaround it is still very dense and overgrown..
With some mimosa trees, some old branches that arethere...
So we still need to clean up the area
around it a bit, so we have space.
But also for thefire season that is coming,
to make sure we remove the 'fuel'...
And we're gonna make a big roof on topof the container.
It's going to be the biggest roof we have until now!
And we mainly want this, becausewe want
to store things very dry in the container.
But also, create some dry spaces on the edges ofit,
so we can store wood, metal, our waste system...
The roof itself will be mounted on these four,
solid corners, which containers always have.
Wait, let me actually show you up close...
They look a bit rough, butthey're super sturdy
and standardized around the world.
So the drying would be replicable to othercontainers.
And, for us, it also means in the future
that we can take it on and off, if we want to.
Because it's a very solid connection.
And the outside of the container is in pretty rough condition...
Veryrusty...
But I think we'll just leave it like that,
because we're going to have a big roof on top, thatwill protect it...
And these containers are also very resistant against all the rust.
So it should beokay...
But the inside we're gonna make very nice and clean.
Organized with tools and bulk storage.
But before we're going to do any of that...
- We will need to clear a bit more around it.
We need to make somespace around the container.
And in case you don't know, our land is fully
overgrown with invasivetree species...
This, in combination with having the summer
around the corner, means wildfires arecoming.
A big reason to take flammable mimosas down!
Okay, one patch down!
Anotherone to come!
With the new gloves...
Not in shape yet...
It's the beginning of the season...
It's catching fire...
After we chopped allthe mimosas, we burned all the brambles,
and the things that could spread a fire.
And, as we have a lot of logs now, we offer them to the neighbors
Who use them forwarming up their house in the winter.
And we also had help from Benjamin,
toturn the leftovers into wood chips.
That will prevent that more mimosas,
andbrambles would grow in the new area.
- Did we finish, Julie?
- Yes.
Enough.
Alright! So, this is a much better pile!
Now we have a lot of wood chips to be spread...
Now that this area is clean,
Dave canstart to build the new storage room.
Now it's a new day.
All the materials for the roof structure arrived,
so wecan start building the frame.
So next, we're gonna make the frame on top ofthe roof.
And make sure we have a way to connect it,
using one long beam on top, with a few nutsand bolts...
So let's see if we can make it fit!
The roof itself is pretty irregular andnot straight,
because there's a lot of bumps...
We want to make sure that it's all flat
before we start building the roof...
So we can put two big beams on both sides
to evenout everything.
On those are also going to be the connector points
where the roofis going to be attached to the container.
Next we're going to make the metal frame.
We need to chop all the metal tubing we have and strips.
So cutting, drilling, andthen welding it together.
So we have these 6-meter-long beams
and theygo all the way back to the container...
But they don't fully fit in.
So if you have to drilla hole in the middle...
Uh, yeah, it doesn't fit...
But in order to make it fit, we couldmake a hole in the container,
so the beam can slide all the way through.
Just need to make a little hole in the container...
And then we can continueto drill all of the holes.
Right there...
- You are not filming?
No, I just started now...
- Ah okay, no, keep going...
All right, so all the metal parts are now cut!
All the bracketsand the tubes and next
we're going to weld it.
Now we're going to weldit into a few parts,
that we later can assemble on top of thecontainer.
So now it's time to weld!
All the holders are now welded and secured.
This is the onlywelding we have to do,
because all the rest will be nuts and bolts, holding it together.
Next step: we're going to give this a paint job,
to make sure they're protected.
And then we'regonna assemble everything on the container!
Show your hands!
- Now it's a bit clean, because I cleaned them a bit...
Now they're clean?
- Yeah that's clean. I swear!
Okay!
Sanding and cleaning: done!
Next up: painting.
Okay, so all the parts are now ready!
Wehave the screws, the bolts, the nuts, and wrenches...
Container is here, so today we're going to put itall together!
We have Jaime here to help out!
- Hello, my name is Jaime!
I'm 29 years old, andI'm from Spain.
I've been traveling in my van for the last few years.
Working and developingmy skills as a carpenter
in different parts of Europe.
I came to Project Kamp to experience
a more self-sustaining, self-sufficient mode of living...
In a community and in a naturalenvironment.
I like to travel, get to know new places, cultures...
And, in the future, Iwould like to buy
a piece of land with a ruin to rebuild it....
And life a lifestyle that ismore environment-friendly.
So let's start working!
So, next, we're gonna connect the frame tothe container.
So we made these brackets that we put underneath...
And then we can bolt them together...
So they clamp themselves tothe container,
and it should be solid.
So next is the last layer on the frame.
It'stwo different tubes...
So in order to bring them together,
we have this little piece of wood thatgoes into the tube...
And we hammer it in there.
And then the other one aswell
Then, we make sure they're all aligned,
and we screw them onto the frame.
- It's dirty...
So theroof is now ready with the frame!
It's pretty smooth!
And next, we're gonna put onthe roof.
Next, we need to get the materials for the roof
We picked them up on our brand newpickup,
which we renovated in previous video.
It's great to have a bigger sturdy car,
to beable to get larger things ourselves.
And, for the roofing material, we went for metal sheets,
whichis very commonly used around here...
You can find more information in the research module,
on whywe're using this material.
And there you can also download all the files to build the frame.
The linkis posted below!
For now: time to put on the roof.
So the first panel is on...
What are we going to do now?
- I'm gonna drill the first hole...
And we alreadycreated some shade!
- A bit.
There -- a rectangular shade.
- I think shade is going to come, when theroof is up...
It's gonna be a hot evening!
I'm currently on the roof, and everything is finished
But, I kind of cannot get off...
The plan is to jump in that pile of wood chips,
and hopefully everything is okay...
The assembling of the roof went surprisinglysmooth!
All the pieces fitted without a problem,
and we assembled everything inone day!
But just as you finish the roof and wanted to get a dinner,
a guy showed up with his big digger...
He should come on Saturday, but he just came today,
because he is goingto flatten the area around it.
Which is going to be nice in the future,
because then it'sall flattened.
And he also will take out the roots,
that we didn't manage to doourselves before...
So, yeah...
Final touches!
Alright, so...
The roof is now ready!
We already tested it yesterday,with some rain coming in...
Perfectly dry underneath, so that's good.
Thenext steps are going to be making space on the back side,
to store material like wood and metal, that we have leftover.
And, on this side, it's going to be a waste system,
where we can sort out all our trash.
On the inside, we're going to store the gardentools and bulk food.
But, that's for later videos...
If you want to see those, make sureto subscribe.
So you're going to continue to follow how this is going to go.
And if you alreadywant to see the next video for next week,
make sure to subscribe and support on Patreon.
So you can see it one week ahead!
But if not, no worries...
You are going to see us same time, same channel, next week!
Thanks for watching!
It's very strong!
That was it.
Thanks for watching.